e
just just a heads up up we're going to
get started here in a few minutes um
we're we're not used to a noon kickoff I
think
e
um being afternoon
uh I'm going to go ahead and call into
session um division 3's work session
today we've got nine bills to look at
we've we're going to try to get through
five of them before 2 o'cl there are
some more complicated ones that'll start
after two um the the issue uh that I'm
sort of thumb wrestling right now is
that we have three of our division 3
people who are occupied simultaneously
over in this other meeting and um so I'm
I'm I'm I'm going to call a 5 minute
recess uh immediately it's just to
figure out what we're going to do about
the missing three people to the division
so it's just going to take a moment
recess for five
minutes M Mr
chair
on
e
Vision three work session out of recess
uh
Mickey can c can you ver validate that
we're U being broadcast or streamed or
whatever the correct term
is please um and so we're down uh three
people two two Republicans one uh
Democrat that's that's potentially the
margin of error here so so but we're
going to try to move through these bills
um uh to to see if we can resolve some
of them today so that the clerk can be
messing with it and get them ready for a
house vote uh earlier rather than later
so um we're going to go and then we're
going to stop if we are finished before
2 o'cl we've got four bills at 2 o'clock
that uh that we'll start working through
so if you're here for 1588 1593 159 8
1573 if you're here for any of those um
you've got time to go get a cup of
coffee at least so I'm going to start
with um 1564 relative to the child
support
guidelines is there anyone here in the
uh audience that came to speak
specifically about
1564 not seeing any do is there a
motion on
1564 oh do you have a motion I do have a
motion make a motion about to pass uh is
there a
second second okay any discussion would
you like to discuss your
motion
sure
um I've heard people say that
1564 um is a widely accepted bill it
came out of committee unanimously it was
passed on a Voice vote on the house
floor um quote it's a no-brainer um I
believe that this is
an um pretty reasonable um one to move
forward right now and I would appreciate
the support of the division
members any other
discussion uh go ahead represent stream
uh this just one comment and that is
there are some costs to implement this
and I just want to make sure the
committee understands that um uh I I
believe with the bill and coming out of
finances that our recommendation is that
that the $90,000 of of cost is going to
come out of existing funds with no
additional appropriation and whether
that's uh supported by the rest of the
committee otherwise I'm uh 100% behind
OTP um excellent uh uh is there anyone
uh who opposes us executing this and and
we don't formally exec but exact like
let vote it out of the division to send
it to the finance Comm committee is
there anyone opposed to are doing that
now not not not no opposition um I am
concerned about the bill so do do you
want to speak to your position
absolutely um I I do think there's value
in sending the bills to the Senate and
having them take a look at these we have
two bills that affect the same section
of statutes that impact the same
families in different ways and while I
believe there might be an amendment to
help make them more mutually compatible
um passing this one first without taking
up the other one is a little bit
concerning I'd rather study this one or
hold this one and have the other one
discussed and then take them both up at
the
end as of now I'm I would be um a nay
vote on autop pass and an inum study
motion or at least wait until we take
them both up at the same
time I I I hear you and um I'm probably
violating some house rule or protocol on
talking about two bills when one is up
um um but we're a work session and I
think we have more flexibility than
others uh it it it's my thought that we
we go ahead and pass
1564 it's got strong support as uh
representative tersi summarized for us
it's got di Minimus cost as
representative Stringham said to us I I
I I'd like to go ahead and get it uh
passed and uh use it sort of as a as a
baseline sort of the mothership that
we'll talk about 95 in a moment to
figure out how the two bills uh interact
with one another that that that's my
goal okay so are you ready to no
objection to that plan are you ready to
record a vote I
am um let's see for uh representative uh
Lon
yes okay representative Earth is not
here a representative hle
no uh representative wer is not here
representative walner is not here
representative
tersi
yes uh representative Stringham votes
yes representative priest
yes uh chairman Edwards yes the vote
being 5 to
one uh the motion
passes
um with with that um I'll assign um me
to write the uh the
blurb um all right with um Okay so we've
resolved
1564 uh let's open the discussion on
1595 um I understand there's an
amendment and I I think it's Scott
Edwards on it and I is is Miss Rebecca
Hutchins here would you please take a
seat at the at the guest
table yeah please
thanks okay so oh oh welcome
uh just so you know uh we we went ahead
and heard 1564 and voted it out 5 to1 uh
there was really no controversy there
we're now on
1595 um to
t595 uh We've um in division three we've
had two prior work sessions we've talked
about 1595 a couple of times uh and so
uh I'm going to um assume from that that
the members of division 3 have a working
familiarity with the what 1595 does and
with that I think it's okay for you to
go ahead and explain what you intended
to do with this
amendment thank you um for the record
Rebecca Hutchins I'm from Dober New
Hampshire um
so there was a question um whether or
not there was overlap between
1564 and 1595 and so so um I took uh a
the opportunity to to really look at
both pieces of legislation and analyze
where the overlap was and put together
an amendment to remove any overlap I I
am so sorry I should have invited
representative bigford to come sit with
you because it's he's the prime sponsor
of the bill so my my apologies sir that
was just an oversight on my part and I'm
sorry to interrupt you miss
Hutchin
it's quite all
right um so I handed out a a small
handout that kind of talks through um
where there was overlap in the two
pieces of legislation and just to to
clarify any confusion about that and to
show how the amendment just removes any
overlap of these two bills so that they
can both live quite
independently um the four sections of
law that uh both bills deal with um you
can see that in two of those uh so the
The Columns at the top show those four
sections there's uh RSA 458 C chins R
RSA 458 C5 is the adjustment of the
application of guidelines under special
circumstances that's where the bulk of
1564 deals with and then RSA 458 C3 is
where the bulk of 1595 deals with and
there are no changes on 1564 to that
section of Law and then there's a small
um definition in RSA 461 that uh
hb564 put in you can see on the first
page the areas of red that just show the
overlap so the it's actually quite small
in the definitions really there was just
an overlap on the the word the
definition of parenting time and so what
we've done in the amendment is adopt the
definition that
hb564 used and then just add on to that
a little bit about how you use that in a
calculation essentially you need to
equal 100% if you're talking about uh
multiple people and parenting
time um and then the second section of
law um the adjustments what we've done
with the amendment is just remove any uh
anything that we had in that section of
the statute
um so that there now is no o no overlap
so the amendment that's in front of you
uh just adjusts parenting time as a
definition and removes uh any part that
we had in the adjustments to the
application of the
guidelines all right um so so just so
the division knows where I'm leaning on
this and where there's still plenty of
time to discuss this and disagree
potentially
was um I uh I I got a call from Miss
Hutchins late last week she's been
following this issue with representative
bigford for quite a while she sat in on
our previous work sessions and she said
she had a good idea on how to get the
two bills to coexist and not conflict
with each other and uh then I I was kind
of a bit of a jerk with her I said hey
at this point this late in the process
what you would need to do is you would
need to put a side by side together and
you'd need to draft the amendment
because there's just no time and she did
all of that happily and willingly and
it's here on time and I just want to
really thank you for being an involved
active uh Citizen and like to see in the
legislature someday so uh uh
representative bigford um do you have
any uh comments about the amendment have
you seen it do you have an opinion sir I
I don't see any problem with it um I
when we started our working group um
actually she is our lead person there
and that's what she does for living is
problem solving for companies Etc
um and no that she's I think she's
solved the problem CU when we started we
didn't know what the other Bill had in
it so we wrote you know how they come
out and it's like uh oh this but we
didn't know where it was going so this
solves all that problem and this is
really good bill I mean this is this is
the bill that was recommended for New
Hampshire from the study that New
Hampshire did and paid
$114,000 for plus the
$140,000 from 2018 so it's and it fills
that middle ground in May heard me on
the floor I spoke about I say you've got
the single parent over here and now
we've got the uh with 64 is uh a a a way
of going into uh two parents a shared
parenting situation uh almost
equal and so but we need something in
between and that's what that's what this
asks us to do to uh create that
representative H is your comment for
work session for between the division or
do you have questions I have a question
please ask your question representative
Bickford so I have in my notes Here an
amendment uh
104h which was handed in during the last
work session affecting section five of
the bill I have the amendment from
Edwards which affects only section
two is the intent to adopt both of these
concurrently or just adopt 101 sorry
1172 and ignore the section changes to
five except uh 1172 and ignore the
previous
one thank
you and and so by ignoring it we just
don't even need to introduce uce it so
um go representative Leon uh thank you
Mr chair I still want to call you Leon
it's not so fancy lay on um I and I just
wanted to note on lines 15 and 16 of
this new Amendment it actually deletes
section five so it deals with it that
way all right Mickey I I I forget what
the order of this is do we have to uh
introduce um um 1593 first and then the
amendment or 1595 first and then the
amendment or do we do the amendment
first and then the the underlying
Bill I'm not familiar with the division
three practices I can tell you I think
you'd probably be okay with somebody
making a motion on adopting Amendment
1172 and then take the bill up ought to
pass as amended all right I I need a a
motion to go ahead go ahead and the if
it's a question for the work session
let's introduce and then Talk Amongst
ourselves I think you're supposed to
introduce the bill and talk to the bill
if so um do you want to make the motion
to I'll move the amendment 1172 H for
the purpose of having a discussion right
now is there is there a
second second okay so uh we can now
discuss the amendment representative
torki sure um thank you one of the
concerns that I heard um about 159 95 is
it doesn't take into account situations
um of domestic violence and um would
this amendment address that concern or
does the bill still stay silent stay
silent going that yeah um so
the the hope is that both bills pass
together and the domestic violence uh
portion that was put into 1564 would
stand with this also in it so it's the
domestic violence um piece was a small
Clause that went into the deviation
section to remind folks of uh another
section of law that protects domestic
violence as any um Court when they're
reviewing child support
orders no that answered my
question representative H did you have a
question do you have a comment for the
work session for the good of the
division um I would support the adoption
of 1172 to
1595 um I would move a to pass on the
adoption of the amendment so we could
have right these bills work concurrently
um as they go over to the Senate thank
you is there F any further discussion on
uh OTP of
1172 not not seeing any representative
Stringham are you ready to call a
vote representative Edwards I'm sorry I
think that there was some consideration
of the effective date of this amendment
I just want to make sure the committee
is comfortable with how it is the
underlying bill is 1 January 2025 that
that's correct that is an excellent
observation because what this one didn't
do was it didn't change the effective
date to 1 July 25 and so right now OS is
cooking another version that actually
has it in the text and that was the one
that just didn't make it today so we're
using this 11 72 is a
discussion so so I I don't I don't know
that
uh I know we have a proper motion um but
I would like to whoever made it to
resend it because we don't really want
to vote on 1172 we have an amendment
coming to change the effective date go
ahead how about I amend my motion to
adopt
1172 with the
additional change to the effective date
being July 1st 2025 I I I think that's
acceptable who second it you second it
okay so um so do you understand the
motion uh represent string I do okay do
you do you want to call a vote yeah so
the the vote is on Amendment 1172 to HB
1595 uh with the change of an
implementation date of July 1
2025 which may change the the amendment
number uh but n unth less this vote
would carry that so and the motion is
ought to pass um representative Leon yes
representative Earth
Earth yes representative hle yes
representative Wier yes Representative
walner no Representative tersi
no uh representative Stringham votes yes
representative priest yes
uh uh and uh chairman
Edwards I I'm a yes vote being seven to
two uh the amendment uh with the revised
implementation
passes um okay so let's talk about how
this is going to go down so so when we
do get the the up the
fresh um Amendment it's going to have a
different number than 1172 we just voted
to accept it whatever that number is
Mickey can you just take that and and
pass it on to the clerk's office as as
though we voted for it or do we need to
revisit this you'll revisit it in the
full committee so when division three
brings its recommendations to the full
committee we'll have that Amendment yep
thank
you uh do representative walner uh
representative tersi do you have like a
sentence or two you want to share with
us on on your your no I mean we've
already voted but I I'm just curious if
you have a concern that we should know
about okay all right so who did we say
is going to write that blurb I think we
said that you
will I don't think we I don't think we
have a blur on an amendment am we have
to vote on the bill okay all right so is
there a motion on HB 1595 I'll move I
move a to pass as as Amendment as
amended with the amendment number to be
determined based on the description we
just had of 1172 plus a change of date
okay um this there
second second all
right you ready for the vote um I guess
I have a brief comment I don't know if
anybody else does before voting um you
know having having uh spoken
to um Miss Hutchin and uh other
Representatives and listening to the
dialogue we've had here uh I do think
there are um there are legitimate policy
concerns about 1595 that led it to be a
closer vote rather than the unanimous
vote of of 15 um
74 or 64 thank you uh those issues
mainly mainly about whether the policy
formula is Broad enough or not um um uh
I um in my opinion that the bills can
coexist if the policy for each is
supported so I intend to support
1595 and if there are are issues to be
worked out I and uh uh you know there's
still still concerns that uh that they
be addressed in the Senate so I plan to
support uh 1595 as
amended all right is there any further
comment uh representative tki thank you
um I think this is a very complicated
issue I think that the work we've barely
dug into demonstrates that um I would
support a different motion preferably
interim study that would allow um a
little more in-depth understanding of um
where this bill would actually bring us
so unfortunately I'm going to be voting
no on the motion that's on the floor
right
now so so since you raised the
conversation point of interim study is
there anyone else who's thinking interim
study as opposed to an
otpa I mean we have the motion of otpa
but we're just
talking did you have a
comment I have I really don't have a
comment at this point other than I would
support a to pass because I do interim
study I'm sorry um you know I do think
there it's complicated and it's we're
talking about policy all of this is
policy and um not the not the financial
part of the bill and um for that reason
I just think we
should leave it for interm study and
come back to
it anyone else thinking that
representative all your light us on it
is thank you um in term it is policy and
at some level some of this directly
impacts the court costs and although
this is division three if we can leave
um a policy in place that has reasonable
math rules to allow judges to make
decisions we should theoretically
shorten the amount of time spent in the
courtroom which could be advantageous
financially so yet one more reason why
I'm supporting
AAS any other further conversation on
otpa or thoughts on is interm
study not not not any um are you ready
for a
vote yep so this is a vote on U House
Bill 1595 is amended with a
1172 or successor Amendment uh put
forward by representative hle and I
believe seconded by uh by Speaker Wier
chairman wer
uh representative Leon
yes representative F yes representative
hle yes representative Wier yes
representative
walner Representative tersi no
representative Stringham says yes
representative priest
yes uh chairman Edwards uh yes vote 7
to2 uh ought to pass um so I would
expect well I'll leave leave the next
part to you chairman about the Okay so
so I'm going to close 1595 and thank you
for all your work um appreciate it uh
obviously this is not done it's got to
go to the full finance committee the
house and the Senate so so the steeple
chase continues all right hey thank
you uh turn on your mic
on thank you I I wanted to ask about the
fiscal note does this change I mean does
it come up become a zero or or because
the other one's already gone through so
you have so I'm going to lean on Mickey
but what I think happens is um the an
official fiscal note doesn't get updated
until the house passes
it that that's what I think happens is
that is that close that's correct that's
correct okay all right so don't ask me
any more questions I got one in a row so
uh any anything else representative
bigford yeah thank you very much for all
the time you thank Miss Hutchins this
this this was to me it was dead last
week thank you yeah so so thank
you represent hold do we know when the
proposed amendment is going to come from
OS with the updated
date I I can tell you the request was uh
sent over over the weekend so I'm not
sure we we asked for it and we'll get it
as soon as all ask can I'm monitoring my
email now so if we get it during the
work session today I'll let everybody
know
that would be great thank
you okay uh represent priest uh before
um the witnesses or testimonies leave I
I would have a question for you where in
1564 does it discuss the cases of
domestic abuse so if you look at the um
the chart that I sent over um RSA 45 8
C5 is where you see uh that section um
about domestic violence it's at the end
of page two um I'm G to I don't have it
in front of me but the line numbers on
my chart tell me that it's probably
around line 20 of page two on HB
1564 I'm done thank
you all right uh with that I I think we
can completely change subjects and I'm
I'm going to open on um HB
1282 do we do we have anyone here who
wants to speak to
1282 this is relative to the duration of
child support in our previous work
sessions there really hasn't been any
controversy on this um so I don't know
that we need to discuss it for further
today uh I I would be willing to
entertain a
motion a brief question go ahead I'm
looking at my notes here and I think it
says the effective date also needed to
change did we have an amendment for that
that I'm
missing I'm thinking that one slipped by
us
uh I as I look at my notes yeah there
was uh an amendment that got triggered
because we were told it take six months
to do the contract and six months to
implement it and and uh I I I don't I
don't uh recall ever hearing anything or
asking Mr Ripple to generate the
amendment though so
um so I do think that that would be
reasonable to get the amendment all
right would you like me to do that or
can someone else draft it so not not of
being here at the previous work session
the bill as introduced had an effective
date of 60 days after passage it looks
like the amendment out of the policy
committee changed the effective date to
1 January 25 so it's possible I don't
know if that triggered any recollection
I think we were looking at one July 25
yes so I I do not have any amendments
for this bill just so everyone's aware
of that so can you ask for one
um can we still do the same thing and
vote on it with that modification I'm
okay with that because it's still got to
go to the finance committee so we've got
some a fallback we're operating with a
net here so I I'm okay with that is
there any objection to going ahead and
and U discussing this considering a vote
knowing that we want the amendment to
reflect one July 25 for the
implementation date
effective date
rather okay I'm not I'm not seeing
anyone objecting to that was there was
there a motion already on on
1282 there wasn't there was not anyone
care to make a
motion representative tki I'll make a
motion of ought to pass on 1282 with the
Proviso that sorry with the provision of
an upcoming amendment that will change
the effective date to July one okay is
there a
second second I'll second and then
seconded any further
discussion I'm I'm not seeing any are
you ready for a vote could I just ask a
question to make sure we do this the
right way go ahead should we also vote
on the amendment this proposed amendment
separately or should we just vote on the
otpa again not sure how division 3 te
technically runs you know in the past
you could do both just as a belt and
suspenders show a hands how many are
willing to okay so we're all in favor of
that and and so this would turn out to
be an otpa
vote are you are you okay yep
representative
L yes representative Earth yes
representative hle yes representative
Wier yes representative walner yes
representative tersi yes Stringham votes
yes representative priest yes chairman
Edwards yes
90 all
right thank you there's just something
rewarding about knowing things are in
the rearview mirror um okay so we have a
1669 uh I know this one has an amendment
being offered by representative Leon lay
lay
[Music]
on
okay um and uh from where you're
sitting um why don't you just uh with we
don't have a motion yet so but because
no one knows what your Amendment says
why don't why don't you talk to us about
what you think your Amendment does to
the underlying bill um thank you so um
with this bill um and currently says the
department shall not share this
personally identifiable information
unless the department is able to ensure
the withdrawals the amendment changes it
to say that prior to entering into an
agreement to share personally
identifiable information um the
department shall ensure that withdrawals
will be honored so the the point with
this is that whether or not that money
is available this year this would make
it so that that needs to happen before
anything is shared um that would be able
to remove any fiscal impact from this
bill uh because there's there as far as
I'm I'm aware there are no current plans
in order to share that information and
since there are no current plans to
share that information the question is
whether or not the funds are available
in order to spend the money to update
the system to allow that data to comply
with our other existing laws prior to it
being shared so it's simply a matter of
whether or not we want to allocate the
money for somebody to
um be able to update the database now or
if that's something that we would look
to do in the new budget cycle because
there is no pending um pending agreement
to share those data so this allows the
flexibility that we would need so may I
clarify yes okay so we're talking about
Amendment
1073 correct and the operative change of
the word to shall is that on line seven
the department shall uh so the operative
changes are
um on line five
the from prior to entering into an
agreement two replaces the words the
department shall not and then when you
get
to immunization systems um at the very
beginning of line seven it previously
said unless the department is able to
assure that withdrawals under paragraph
3A now it says that that they shall
ensure the withdrawals so instead of um
instead of saying that the department
shall not unless it says prior to an
enter entering an agreement they
shall okay and do you recall uh what how
you were on the committee so do you
recall what 1669 how uh HHS looked at
this from a policy perspective um I will
confirm but I'm pretty certain that it
was on the consent calendar okay and
what you think this amendment does is it
removes the fiscal impact um it leaves
that to be more of a choice as to
whether it wants to be funded but yes
that way if the funds aren't available
this year we still have it into law that
it's necessary and we'll know that it's
it'll be necessary to um pay for that
prior to sharing our information okay so
we're in the part of the discussion
where we're all trying to understand the
amendment and the underlying Bill
representative tki thank you I have a
question perhaps Mr White could chime in
on his interpretation of the amendment
and what it means
for the future the future fiscal future
fiscal okay if
what monies May pay for that if we're
going to have to dig for that but just a
little clarification on their
interpretation
thanks you can you can grab a mic at the
end Mr
White hi uh good afternoon I'm Abby
Rogers uh legislative lays on division
of Public Health Services and I'm me and
Marie mcui I'm the immunization section
chief thank you um so I think that one
of the things that we just want to
clarify is that um we would not be
entering into agreement with any other
state to share until we had dialogues
with the other states to really kind of
understand their ability to comply with
any terms um that has been uh put
forward with legal consultation um but
we would need to have the system
upgraded before entering into the
agreement so that would be very
important to know that that money's um
those funds would need to be available
prior to entering into those agreements
um because because it would be uh
unreasonable for us to proceed forward
with an agreement say with Vermont um
when we then have to turn around and say
it's going to take us six to nine months
to upgrade our system and uh we're going
to have to put you on hold even though
we have this agreement in
inforced so so this I guess this will
end up with Mr White but it's my
recollection that we funded this this
system in the prior budget that the that
the money to implement a an immunization
system is already in the budget is is
that false or
true that that my understanding is that
is that's true but but as far as system
change requirements go um this would be
the enhancement so similar to the past
two bills where there's a $100,000
general fund impact for the system
requirements this would be similar I I I
haven't seen the updated Amendment
language um but but I I would ultimately
defer to Dave weers on what the full and
final impact would
be all right I I can't imagine it to be
very conse consequential distinction
from the underlying bill because the two
changes that I've heard representative
Leon uh Leon say uh don't seem to
substantively change what we're wanting
to do we're just clarifying the right
words to say what we want to do so I
don't with this amendment I don't see
any change from the underlying 1669
would would you agree or disagree Mr I I
haven't seen a copy of the amendment so
I can't speak to it oh okay well he's
looking at that ask a procedural
question uh yes sir I note that this has
representative lon's name on it and I
don't believe that can count we'll have
to have another amendment drawn up I
think with with your name on it or
somebody's name from the committee
correct you know we we're going to see a
Pearson Amendment later so this is a
good conversation I can we accept an
Amendment within finance that does not
have a permanent Finance person on the
named I think typically the practice is
we would switch it over to a house
finance member's name at some point so
uh whether that's between here and the
full Committee just to redraft it with a
sponsor that's on on house
finance how how are we doing on on
effective dates we don't did we did is
this one that we wanted to talk about an
effective date up
modification and did we do that no in
this case we want it to be 60 days
because this is a higher level policy
that ensures that that we're not sharing
the data okay is this just an
administrative thing where we go to ol
Mickey to OS and just say hey change the
name of the of that Amendment without
changing the number or anything the
number will change but we can redraft it
with the content identical of course
with just the change in the sponsor okay
does anyone love this amendment that
they want their name on it
uh I I'm I I love this amendment I love
this amendment put it under
both okay put put the representative
hole on it because he doesn't agree with
us very often so
let's let's make
he
um all right
um so is there is there understanding of
this underlying Amendment we haven't
really discussed whether we like it or
not yet but
do do you have more to say go ahead um I
guess my one question would be that um
do you see that this would prohibit you
from making this change if the funds
were available um that you could still
proceed the same way with this language
um it's just would allow you to press
push it out if there was any funding
issues um I don't think that we have an
issue with the language as long as the
intention is that we would have the
funds to develop the the enhancement
prior to entering into that agreement
thank
you I I want to see if Mr White has a
comment yet on okay go ahead represent
hle I'm not sure who in the department
to answer this on on line five PR prior
to entering into any agreement it's my
understanding agreement is in the
broadest sense of the word meaning memor
memorandum of understanding the entire
list of potential words that would fall
under agreement is that the same
understanding that you guys have that is
true this would be um to enact
anou represent
priest thank you Mr chairman again from
my understanding this um the previous
fiscal impact report stated that there
was a
3.2
million that was needed at the beginning
is this the enhancement or is this the
program being
upgraded I'd like to defer to
representative L please um thank you
there was an amendment adopted in the
policy committee Health and Human
Services initially the bill had been
introduced where a person could choose
to share the information and by being
able to do that and track where it went
that what brought in the 3 million
charge we removed that because I thought
that it would be a nice benefit to be
able to allow people to share that but
their immunization records are their own
and they can share that from their
existing medical record I over
complicated things to the cost of $3
million and we fixed that in Health and
Human Services before it went to the
floor and uh I had wanted to make a note
because I realized that it didn't have
an updated uh fiscal impact fiscal note
on there and it is $3 million less now
um yeah there is a new
note there is a new note which has it at
$61,000 $181,000 in 2025 100,000 in 26
and
27 okay but but the underlying system is
has we've funded the underlying system
this this this the money that you're
referring to I believe is uh to modify
or update the system the the numbers I
just referred to are regarding the
current state of the amended bill as
opposed to the original $3 million plus
PR price tag
and I don't believe well so I do believe
it's related to the current bill but I
think we did fund the underlying system
separately and I if I'm wrong I want to
be told I'm wrong right ra if I could
clarify so the the updated fiscal note
reflects the six the onetime $60 to
80,000 upgrade if this legislation would
pass plus a position to run the trans
transaction reports that's the current
fiscal what the fiscal note represents O
Okay so I think you just agreed with me
we've already funded the underlying
system that this system has been
previously funded but that would be for
routine operations and maintenance this
would be above and beyond that as an
enhan I just wanted everyone to have a
common understanding that the base
system is paid for and and this is
additional money to support the
incremental changes needed by this
legislation right correct we're all
saying the same thing representative tki
thank you I just want to dig a Little
Deeper to make sure I understand what I
heard was the lay on Amendment though
because it just sort of sets an
expectation removes the actual fiscal
note removes any additional cost is that
correct my understanding is that that
would allow the flexibility because it's
not requiring them to do that right now
so um if there's if there's not funding
that it could be done in the future
before there's anou okay so my question
then goes back
to if they decide to pursue this let's
say Vermont you want to develop that
connection with and you need to do this
my question sort of is where's that
money going to come from at that
point I don't know who I'm directing
that at I I I would think if if it's
authorized in law and they want to do it
and they run it through the governor's
budget that it would be a budget item in
the next budget so it would be the next
budget year it's not something that
could be happen in the next 5 months if
that arises unless they have uh funds
already within the broad budget to to do
that do do you want to speak now
representative wer or Mr White has
something to say
too they have the flexibility within
their budget they could come to fiscal
and transfer money but if if the money's
already there within that computer line
and it's the EIT line it could be if
there's money there otherwise they could
move it from somewhere else we always
expect them to to lapse millions of
dollars sometimes they do sometimes they
don't so you know that could be an
excuse they could come to fiscal if they
wanted to move it within their own
budget and it was more than what was
there but there's ways they can do that
thank you very much Mr White I don't
know if you would Mr White did you have
a comment no no more more uh following
up on what uh chairman wer was saying um
no we we do not not have any funds
explicitly budgeted for this enhancement
or the enhancement of the prior two
bills um some years we laps more money
than others this year we're not
projecting to lapse a whole lot um but
things can change between now and June
um so we won't know but those funds will
lapse they wouldn't necessarily be used
for this public health generally
speaking is significantly higher federal
funds there's fewer General funds
available and there's a lot less
flexibility within their budget comp
compared to other areas to the
likelihood of being able to find public
health dollars within the existing
budget is probably fairly
minimal thank
you Mr
chair yeah so if I if I understand the
department is that even with the
implementation of this amendment um your
preference would be to or or that your
practice would be to go ahead and start
getting the systems ready to handle it
and therefore uh the expense that are
involved in in the fiscal note that we
have is amended by the house uh uh 1619
h which called for1 161 to
$181,000 of Appropriations in this
bium um um would would would be needed
you know to implement the bill as as as
amended thank you for the question uh
currently we don't share information
with other states but in preparation to
do so if we did do so we would need
those funds in order to bring the system
up up to um to do that it's 100% of this
out of the general fund or laap fund or
some of it would some of it come from
federal
government um there would probably be a
match of some sort but today we do not
have these funds
budgeted
right okay thank
you question for Mr White is this a 50
50 Style Match do you know it would
depend on the specific funding sources I
think it's higher is it I don't know up
the top of my head might be
two represent W this is I think a
question for Mr
White so the fiscal Note require is
talking about the development of a um a
specialist for position so would you
need
Authority within the bill to hire this
position there so if I may not note note
that the fiscal note got updated and the
fiscal are you referring to fiscal note
2655 yeah okay all right go ahead sure
um there's a couple of ways that
positions can be created if we receive a
new Federal grant we can come through
fiscal and have fiscal establish a
position there's also a way to establish
temporary full-time position via Das
however again there's been no
appropriation given here so we wouldn't
anticipate on doing that anytime soon um
as you know we reported to the fiscal
committee that our estimated lapse
projections are going to be currently
less than last year and we still have
our $23 million general fund back the
budget cut to
hit I think this is a question question
for our chairman of
Finance would it be appropriate to have
an amendment to the amendment that
authorizes the funding in the position
to do this I don't know how this is done
well I understand you want it this to go
into effect immediately so yes that
would be the only way it could happen if
if we started to put an appropriation
that was available it's not otherwise
appropriate so there's been nothing to
stop a member of division three from
submitting an amendment to that effect
uh yeah so so if we took the amendment I
handed mine off but if we took the
amendment uh 1073 H and added to it
right because of the inment date that
the funding mechanism is there and that
the necessary positions are taken care
of could that be drafted in preparation
for our full exact
meeting are are you owning the amendment
or is this still absolutely okay so this
is this is the whole amendment that
you're proposing and is then the
question is can it be ready by or vote
on Friday because we have one more day
to do this yeah sure I I I think it can
and yeah okay so so work with Mickey to
figure out how you want that Amendment
and uh we can uh defer a vote on this
until we see your Amendment and we'll
we'll carry it over till
Friday
question would it be possible to have an
update fiscal with everything on it by
Friday formally the answer is no because
until the house votes on it the LBA
doesn't generate new fiscal notes what
what what Mr Ripple has done and maybe
Mickey has done this as well is
sometimes he's done like a back of the
envelope swag so that we have some idea
what kind of money we're talking about
but the the obligation to create a full
fisc a formal fiscal note doesn't occur
until after the bill is changed on the
floor
okay thank you for the clarification
representative string yeah I would say
that um that the fiscal note that 2655
is going to be very similar to what the
fiscal n note would be coming out of the
uh this amended Bill and representative
HS because basically the Department's
telling us if you want us to prare for
this we have to spend the money and the
amendment that we just looked at today
basically basically said please you know
you're not required to spend any money
till you want to go but the department
would like to move ahead and the
amendment that we're going to see is
going to say let's appropriate the money
so they can make the preparations and I
think it'll be these
amounts um thank you and I think you're
talking about the amended version of
2655 that was amended on March 6 correct
that's correct 0619 H so and the
expenditures are more in the 161 to 168
in this bium and another couple hundred,
next bium thank
you okay for for for
cleanliness uh it would be nice if the
if uh
1073 which needs to be updated anyways
because it doesn't have a committee
member's name on it if if you took it
along with your appropriation language
and made one clean amendment that we
could consider instead of the two is
there isn't there is there anyone that
objects to the the the concept of
no you're not sure yet I'm still working
on it okay so so if so represented hle
would you would you make sure that
Amendment gets put
together all right um so we're going to
go ahead and um postpone a decision on
1669 until uh Friday uh where we meet
again uh that's already in the calendar
the house calendar so we're good there
um so with that I'll I'll close
discussion on
1669 and open discussion on
1363 this is relative to allowing
members the general court to participate
in the DHHS employee assistance
program
um
representative Nutter Upton am I close
Nutter okay up come on up
friend do do you want to speak to your
you're you're the uh you're the prime
sponsor right and we've not heard from
you yet so we're we're hearing from you
for the first time yes all right thank
you
um it um came to my when you're having a
crisis um it's hard to find all the
resources that you need in that moment
and um I became aware of um
EPA uh assistance programs um at another
job of mine um and um let's see I'm
going to tell a quick story last Tuesday
I stepped out into my yard and noticed
half my roof had blown off a back
kitchen part and it's a mess and I'm
like I don't know what I'm going to do
about this I called my new insurance
company and they said oh we'll send the
adjuster right out and I said do you
have a like an emergency repair crew
that could put a tarp over we do we'll
send Tony out um and so with one phone
call and and they had a list of
contractors because I don't have a list
of contractors and we don't have phone
books anymore you know that was easy so
I realized with this one phone call
everything got taken care of on that day
I was home that day Tony showed up the
adjuster showed up covered this is kind
of what the employee assistance program
can do for our members um your your
child has a drug addiction and and you
find out and and you need some referrals
or some references or gambling problems
or financial problems you know you get
the paper in the mail that says your
husband didn't pay the taxes and like oh
my God anyway so it's like I said when
you're in the middle of a crisis it is
not the best time to try and find all
these resources and that's what employee
assistance program can do and they cover
um lots of subjects and Mr Lawless is
here as is attorney Williams that could
speak if you'd like to hear because they
know um this is very inexpensive as you
know it's less than a
$118,000 ask per year
um and um it's a small thing to offer
our representatives and Senators um we
have stressful jobs and we Face crisises
sometimes I've known of fellow
legislators that have had death threats
uh certainly bereavements and you know
things like that so um the previous
hearing brought up concerns about
defining us as employees because it is
in the title and we can't really change
that but I believe there was an
amendment that um clarified this was
only for the
representatives uh or senators and or
close family members during their term
of office um you know because you know I
understand finance committee probably
likes things like that tidy um so you
refer to another amendment uh you're not
you're it's what you just
described is not in the base bill of
1363 though is it where where it's
limited during term of office yeah I did
have that in an amendment and I'm sorry
I don't have that handy okay but there
is an amendment somewhere I believe it
it didn't get voted on in the house yet
right no no sorry I think it was alluded
to that the policy committee discussed
it as a possibility yes I'm seeing a
head noting but it did not actually get
attached to the bill before it was
voting on so I think the option that the
representative suggesting is that we
draft that amendment to clarify
specifically who it covers and we would
need to bring it forward and term of
coverage okay okay because the only
amendment I'm aware of is the Edward's
amendment to postpone the effective date
on this for 10 years so it doesn't look
to the citizens of New Hampshire that
we're voting ourselves enhanced benefits
right um I would like to bring the other
Amendment and maybe not bring the
Edwards Amendment but that's yours to do
um we have no guarantee any of us will
be reelected you know that's the point
well the the point of the 10-year
amendment is to make sure that it
doesn't look like any of us are behaving
in a self-serving manner I know but I
think 10 years is
Extreme um what would you be comfortable
with um January of
2025 I I think I've heard similar but I
don't have an amendment that says that
so um go representative tki thank you I
would be more than happy to work with
the representative to draft the
amendment with an effective date of the
next bium that none of us know if we'll
be here or not I I want to make sure
that we don't know that I mean that's to
me that's like the critical thing that
we're not voting to uh self- andrise our
own benefit package it should for be a
future one and I I'd be more comfortable
if it was a term or two away you know I
I I I want some distance between us and
the and the enhanced package but are you
are on in your Amendment are you also
going to address the policy discussion
in your Amendment the one that
representative letter upam just
described the notes I took down as an
amendment to clarify that it's only for
elected representatives during their
term of office so the end of their term
of office would be the last day they
could utilize said services and they
wouldn't be able to begin to participate
until the day they were sworn in is what
I would assume be the definition of that
would would you put family members in or
out um I don't Rec I'm sorry can I I
don't recall if the family members were
included in the original bill I I
believe they were or or that's how um
that's how the program works is what
you're saying yeah can we you want to
confer with Mr law no you're no we've
heard that I don't think representative
tki was here that day but okay um
representative wer I'm trying to
remember the discussion on this was this
the one that came from the committee as
inexpedient do you have the dock at
Handy I I do it uh it did come out with
an itl recommendation uh but it passed
on a roll call vote on the house floor
184 to
168 thank
you which shows that the the body is in
favor of it I mean there what we didn't
even have a debate that day we had no
piis and it passed so I agree with not
passing laws that self- enrise ourselves
you know as as lawmakers you know um but
as I point out we don't know that we'll
be reelected so for it to start for the
next term whoever gets
reelected well we'll think about that
represent um I think to comply with the
US Constitution under the 27th Amendment
which was proposed in 1789 but didn't
confirmed until 1992 almost 200 years to
the year um as the adoption cycle we
would have to make sure that this is not
enacted until after the next election
cycle
as a
Minimate representative tki and then
representative walner I was simply going
to suggest that maybe we put the
effective date to be in the next budget
cycle ah or
two we hear you representative distance
makes my heart grow fonder on this one
but that's just me uh representative
Waller okay representative wer did you
have another comment I I I just I was
not in favor of this when it came to the
floor trying to remember what the and as
I I recall there wasn't an itl from the
committee thank
you so one reason that I think this
could be is really important and could
be beneficial it's not just beneficial
yes to the um legislator but I think it
could also be really beneficial to the
operating of the house and
senate for the leadership because when
people do have things that are stressful
to them often they come here with those
issues and whether the advice they get
from fellow legislators or from
leadership is helpful or even
correct um might end up being sort of
detrimental to the the full to the full
house and this way we would know they
were getting good professional advice um
about how to handle the situation or
suggestions about things that might be
available so to me it's almost feels
like a tool for the leadership um to
really be able to be sure people are
getting the best advice that we can be
given um thank you one of the things
that I found most interesting in this
role is when people come to us and they
have challenges especially things where
there are government programs that help
learning that process both when I am
helping a constituent track down how you
address something at the labor labor
department or how you address something
around Medicaid going through the
process that we have for everybody else
in the state and doing that ourselves I
think is a really good way that keeps us
connected because we know better what
the resources are and we share them with
those who come to us up in the grocery
store speaking to us in town or call us
with their challenges and I think that
by by looking to those same resources
and calling them for questions calling
211 calling these other resources makes
it so that we understand better what the
people of New Hampshire also need to do
in order to solve a lot of these
problems and I honestly think that
separating ourselves from that would
mean that we're not as effective at
constituent Services because it's a
little more important when I have a
question and I know this is I'm not
going through back channels to talk to
the legisl ative person I'm I'm reaching
out as just a regular New Hampshire
citizen through the normal channels and
the normal process and then we
experience the same way that all of our
neighbors
do most employees most employers offer
Employee Assistance programs which our
state run in our state I I listened when
I wasn't sure if you were in favor or
not but the the great thing about
employee assistance program is that they
have
um rearrange relationships with
different agencies and whatever and they
know right where to go quickly
not go ahead um I you said that most
people do not everybody in the state
does and many people who are starting up
small businesses are doing other things
that don't have those same resources as
those of us who either ourselves or our
spouses work at a large company they're
the ones that most need to be able to
reach out directly to the state and the
more that we understand that process I
think the more receptive we are to our
neighbors so I I think that putting
ourselves separately and doing this and
doing an employee assistance plan we're
not not employees is something that
bothers me but I think more importantly
it sort of disconnects us from those
citizens who most need the direct
assistance through the state and through
those programs that we have so that's
just I guess a fundamental issue but
that's one I wanted to highlight because
I think that sort of that shared process
is important so so so to take advantage
of the work session part of this let me
ask you a question I I think I just
heard you say you're in favor of the
bill no I'm not in favor of the bill I'm
in favor of doing things the same way as
most of our constituents which those who
don't have any AP need to reach out to
the resources offered okay or no
resources so I I think I understand your
point that there there are small
business owners and the like that don't
have this benefit and making it
available to us is what separ in your
mind separates us from our
constituents yes okay I I I was having
trouble with that so thank you I mean I
I I actually would entertain um a motion
to itl but out of respect uh for your
position representative tersi uh I I'll
wait until Friday to fight this uh you
can bring your Amendment then I I am
absolutely opposed to improving or
creating the appearance of of uh
improving our own benefit package and
and that and that's where I am at it
it's a it's a hard no for me um and the
only way I would be less hard no would
be if this is far enough out in the
future that there's no you know Wink in
a nod that oh I think I'm going to get
reelected next term anyway so I I I just
assume put it out a couple of terms just
so that there's a clear disconnect
between our vote and our benefit that
that that's me but if I go ahead yes if
I may I don't think any one of us would
want to think oo I'm going to pass this
because I intend to have a crisis in 18
months that's going to be life-altering
and um put me in a desperate place um
and I guess that's maybe a
misunderstanding then of what the
program is and and how it would be used
but I appreciate if you would allow me
um that time to draft the amendment
right and I I appreciate your implied
humor and and the way you phrase that uh
but it's like any benefit there's not a
single benefit anyone could bring I mean
it's uh at you know on station
babysitting for example a lot of
employers offer that I would be opposed
to that you know for example I I just
don't think we should be um I think the
Constitution tells us what our benefits
package is it's a $100 a year and and
and I you know that's that's just where
I am but but um so so we can U we'll
just slide this to Friday to talk
further when your amendment is
prepared Friday is the drop dead though
we have to we have to decide Friday yes
sir uh thank you and thank you for
bringing forward your opinions I will
say there's a lot of things that we do
for representatives and Senators that
fall short of being an employee benefit
we have breastfeeding stations uh in the
state house if so if you're a lactating
mother you have a place to go uh we as
the legislator paid for it we have
nursing available uh nurse uh for
emergency care we saw that even even be
of of benefit that is way more expensive
than what this would be I think this is
really addressing the same kind of a uh
kind of an issue not not the same as
having a life insurance or a health
insurance benefit which are more
traditional uh employee benefits uh then
something like this is so that uh uh so
that we have uh a healthy um and
reactive to to crisis uh capabilities
here for for those uh that uh that we at
the state have elected to representes
whether it's us or the ones that follow
us okay that that being said um I
appreciate uh that you would consider uh
voting uh voting for this if say the
implementation date was uh uh two bium
out instead of one so thank you for that
I I'd be I'd be much more open to that
yes yes sir and and on the breastfeeding
station I understand that's also
available to the public if they're on
the complex and they need the Privacy
that that station in the L offers so
it's not just for
Representatives um and I I meant to look
into the nurse I the nurses I think make
sense from an emergent perspective
because we're an elderly
a group of people and just last session
we had somebody who thought they were
having a a heart problem in session so I
think there's kind of an an emergency
part of that um but I don't know to what
extent we're supposed to by policy not
practice but by policy lean on the nurse
for things other than when we're on
campus and we have an emergency I just
don't I haven't had a chance to research
that but uh I will
all right do you have any final words of
wisdom I think you you kind of got a
sense of where we're at thank you for
your time today and thank you I know I
know this is important to
you I I've had EA pre programs offered
in my corporate past and I understand
and appreciate and value the the benefit
so thank you for thinking of
it all right um so that bring brings us
to uh the break uh until 2: p.m. at 2:
p.m. we're going to restart on uh HP
1588 and then knockout 93 98 and 73 and
um and hopefully get home uh before it's
dark so um are there any questions
before I recess till 2
o'clock all right it'll recess till 2
o'clock
ch
e
Mr
chair all right it uh being passed 2 o'
uh we're going to come uh take division
three out of recess and we've got four
more bills to do this evening um and for
those in the crowd uh and and on the
division
uh I will be surprised if we get to the
point of any of these four where we feel
like
we have enough information enough
confidence to send our recommendation to
the full finance committee which means
that we're in a bad spot because if we
don't know how to get from today to
closure on Friday that means we're
really Limited to itls and or interim
studies so we we have to figure out
where we're at today so um that that's
the challenges I see it at this point so
I'm going to bring
1588 into discussion this is relative to
court jurisdiction over persons
receiving special education I understand
that there's a Mr zalon who is supposed
to be here is m m zelon or Mr
come on
up do you have to turn the microphone on
and get really close to it can you hear
me yeah so he had he had to address
another issue I'm Jennifer doof I'm
representing
nhca I'm also the parent of a student
with uh disabilities so so could you
spell what you just said and H I got the
New Hampshire
NHA which is the New Hampshire special
ed administrators Association and we're
part of the legislative committee from
NHA okay thanks I I don't have all my
acronyms up to date so thank you so
we're I I'm a a longtime special
education director and I don't know if
you want to introduce yourself yeah and
um I'm also helping represent the NHA
with uh Jen my name is Jessica Bickford
I am also a special education
administrator and also I'm a parent of a
child with
disabilities okay so I'm looking I'm
looking at my notes and I'm not seeing
an amendment do we have an does anyone
know if we have an amendment to 1588
that we're considering today that's
already ready do you know I have one
Amendment here representative Edwards in
your name that is an effective date
change looks like to one July 25 that's
all it is that's yes okay why why don't
you just hand that out and we'll keep
talking um um all right so I think we're
in sync we're we're we're talking about
1588 and with a different um effective
date so would you like us to get started
yeah go ahead and us so um essentially
our our feeling is that um 1588
addresses a gap that came about um
recently within the last two years the
age of eligibility for special education
was raised to 22 years um and so 1588
addresses the fact that if a student's
out in placement a court ordered
placement for abuse and neglect um the
court uh is required to um discontinue
involvement at 21 this would permit the
court to stay involved up through
22 um and um we understand that uh costs
were brought forward um with 32 students
potentially falling into this category
which we think is a little bit generous
in the sense that that's all of the
students who would continue to be
eligible We Believe for special
education up through 22 these are
students who are typically pretty
significantly disabled and really have
complex needs so if a child for example
couldn't live at home a child with a
developmental disability autism for
example and was you know uh aggressive
and and the parents couldn't manage them
the courts would place them uh out and
they would continue to re receive
special ed up through 22 but if the
court shuts off involvement at 21 they
lose their placement so our feeling is
that the costs would just shift to
another section of DHHS because then it
would the child would have to make sort
of a Hoban decision um the state current
or DHHS currently has a policy where a
student cannot have
placement uh if the students's receiving
special education so the child has to
drop out of special education in order
to have a Community Based placement so
there's a lot of it's kind it's hard to
explain but there's a lot of challenges
and and it really disrupts the lives of
a child um in the short run um and uh
makes you know really disrupts their
life essentially so so I asked uh my
vice chair representative Marine money
to uh take a fresh look at this before
she went on vacation and I'm I'm I'm
sure this was the last thing she thought
of
but I had her go back and and take a
take into consideration that in Prior
terms we've been changing parts of our
law to bring it up to the this new age
standard right and and so the question I
I I put to her uh was you know just give
me your your best assessment on whether
or not we really have a choice at this
point on whether or not we should pass
this bill because it's now just an issue
of getting our laws aligned as opposed
to this being new policy really um and
she said we can either do one of two
things we could either go ahead and pass
this or we could go back and refight the
fights of the last couple of terms that
change the age to begin with and so I I
don't I don't care to do that so so we
have a a narrower U uh decision I think
to make uh representative Stringer
earlier you mentioned some votes on uh
on a bill on what it happened to it in
the house could you do you happen to
have that for this bill I do it uh it
was
120 uh out of committee and
um uh let's see I think the table failed
187 to 188 and then say say that again
the table motion failed 187 to 188 and
then I was pass pass on Voice v okay I
didn't realize it was a tbling motion
yeah so that was pretty close so um I'm
going to bounce over to Mr White um the
the the thing that flagged this is the
was the broad uh Financial estimate of
about 1.6 million to 5.76 million and I
I think what I recall hearing in
previous work sessions is that as more
time has gone on more discussion has
gone on the this cost estimate may have
settled into a a more definitive
narrower range is is that true and if so
what what can you say about that uh no
no I I I believe the conversation we had
relative to that was on a different bill
um the the reason in this case why we
provided such a wide cost range is
because a we're expanding the
population um we're we're adding an
additional year and yes all of those
individuals currently would be receiving
services but we are also going to have
individuals coming into the system on
the other end which is why we basically
straight line the estimate um and we
don't know what service type new
individuals coming into the system would
need which is why we have um the the
various service types listed in the
fiscal note um on the last page and and
that's why we you know for residential
right I pause
there so great okay okay I didn't mean
to cut you off I was just agreeing with
you okay nope I would just basically
speak to the if you look at the table on
the last page you will see the the
variation um or the the the various
estimates that that still
remain okay could I ask a question go
ahead of Mr White um is that the net
cost or the gross cost meaning is that
including the reimbursements the state
would get from Medicaid for these
placements which the state currently
won't place a child in a placement
unless it's Medicaid approved so the
state gets funding back in our
experience there's really not a chance
that there are 32 kids out there this is
a really rare occurrence so it's very
few students annually that fall into
this situation um so I guess looking at
that you know very large amount of
funding that was estimated does that
include the Medicaid reimbursements or
not in the fiscal note we noted that we
were assuming this is 100 % General
funds in this case so it doesn't include
the it does
okay all right then it wouldn't so the
state will get reimbursement for some of
this through because of all the
placements are Medicaid approved and
these are students that similarly to um
if they had their own private insurance
the state could recoup funds that way um
but again it's such a rare occurrence
and it has such a huge impact on each
individual
student Mr Wy if you if you had more
time would do you think uh that could be
used to make this fiscal note more
precise uh because it sounds like there
may be an opportunity to net some money
with Medicaid and private insurance I I
I can take it back to the team we can CL
take a closer look at this um as we've
noted previously we prepared 160 fiscal
notes um in a pretty short time frame
this year um so I'm more than willing to
go back and take a closer look at this
to see if if we can revise any of
this all right is there any other
discussion any thoughts on this I you
now know what where I'm at and what I'm
thinking go ahead represent
wner so I think this is something I
thought I heard the um two women at the
at the table say and that is
that many of these
um people in this category
will become eligible for other programs
that the state offers so if they aren't
in this bucket if they aren't here they
would show up someplace else correct
essentially
so that's an offset financially
also kind of so what happens is when the
student ages out of the Court placement
at 21 currently they have two options
one is either they reject special
education services and then can be
picked up by
DHHS um per RSA
171a so they can be picked up and funded
continuing Adult Services through that
Avenue or they're picked up by the
school and may lose that residential
placement and may be back into the
school setting or a variety of different
other things for one year while until
they're 22 and then can do the Community
Based
Services okay
thank
you qu question represent Stringham um
just just with with 30 I I would hope
that we um you know maybe if we we knew
what the 21y old level of service was um
you know I I understand they could all
be the most severe all be the most least
severe in terms of services used but
there's probably a statistical average
that would give us a little tighter
range than one and a half million to 5 a
half million or whatever the the note
said uh if in the uh course of of of
your revisions on the note if you could
if you could look and see if
statistically if you could tighten up
that a little bit it would be
helpful so so I'm going to ask you a
really dumb question to just prove that
there really are stupid questions look
looking at the table there's a column
for
fy2 if it it if we change take the
amendment and push us out into the new
budget cycle July 125 does that
eliminate the fy2 column and then we're
just looking at 26 and
27 yes
but whether you would want the positions
if any appropriation at all was going to
be provided for the additional case load
um those positions it would probably
take the Department administrative
Services 30 to 90 days to establish the
positions then there'd be some time
before we able to hire them as well so
there would be no cost um if positions
were considered um we would probably
want those available to start day one
but again individuals would be aging
into the system so it may be perfectly
fine okay um so now I have a question
for the
chair representative
wer
um I'm I'm reasonably confident that
this um fiscal note is is is a little
high it's truly representative of a
worst case scenario and and and I and I
think if Mr White had the time and space
to look at this it would probably reduce
this fiscal note um so I I I I have some
reluctance passing something out of
division three to the full committee
without it being fully cooked and and
and now telling you where I think we're
at with this and you receiving this from
us how comfortable would you be that we
still don't we have a squishy fiscal
note
here if we do that
microphone if we do then maybe interim
study is is the way to go until we have
a firmer idea what's happening because
there's some things that are kind of in
in process of going through the 21 to
the 22 makes how many students do it
apply to and those data we we don't have
yet so so so go ahead represent wner
walner well I I guess a lot of it hinges
for me I mean a lot of this fiscal note
really hinges on the numbers of students
we're talking about and it seems like we
should know
how many 21 year olds there are
now it feels like we should be able to
get that figure so we would have a
really closer estimate of how many
would come to us in the next year so I
think and also I well I was also going
back to we we briefly at one point
talked about um needing more casew
workers if there are 32 yeah yes you
might if there are many less than
that you maybe would need less case
workers or an adjustment in the um
Staffing so um it seems to me a lot of
it hinges on the number of students that
fall into this category I I think your
point is brilliant if we knew how many
21y olds there were we would know how
many projected 22 year olds will be
right U but except I think I'm hearing
Mr White say that there's a new category
of of
incremental additions that it isn't just
continuation am I did I mishear you is
it do the 21 year olds continue they
represent the Next Generation or is
there also an influx of newly eligible
the the the 32 number listed in in the
second paragraph on page one that that
is the estimate that we utilized based
on the information that we had available
again I can take this back and I can
verify with the team how they arrived
that number and whether they Ed real
case count data which I assume they did
um to to arrive at that figure and I
think that's the key driver as
representative wner suely pointed out
right so so go ahead represent wner well
I I thought I also heard um them say
that at when they go into that I never
know if it's you're going into the 21st
year or the 22nd year but that ex that
new year that they're eligible for that
they can actually opt not everyone would
opt for that so it's a very small I
think I think it's a very small am I
interrupting it's a yeah it's a very
small number so um it's it's for
students that are not going to earn a
regular high school diploma and it's
students that have not work you know got
earned the credits um and so it's I
think 32 encompasses is all of the
students in the state so it's very rare
that we have a child in a placement
where this has occurred it has it hasn't
happened more than you know once or
twice with groups annually I can't
imagine requiring additional Staffing
because if we raised it to 22 the
schools would continue to case manage
because special ed would still be in
place so that would you know I I can't
imagine hiring new Staffing for you know
just a few kids with very complex needs
where the school is still case managing
and and and funding a big portion of
it because these are only court-ordered
placements that are in this process not
all 21 year
olds so so you just raised a new one if
if the schools are going to continue to
manage these people and they're just
going to have more of them total are we
essentially uh putting a small unfunded
mandate on our schools so I mean the
raising it to 22 has already been done
right so schools schools are going to
end up managing it the problem will be
that currently there's a policy that
they cannot receive um special education
if if if you know
um if dcyf becomes involved if they're
so they have to deny their special
education in which case the Educators
would step away and not be involved at
all and then you would probably need um
RSA
171a you would probably need to hire
folks but it's really just streamlining
things so that hire I'm looking at the
unfunded mandate are we talking about
hiring Folks at the school district
level or at the state level not hiring
anybody we would just Contin allow those
children to stay where they are until
they age out at 22 and the school would
continue to provide those services and
pay for those you know case management
responsibilities I don't I don't know
that I'm explaining my question well
enough uh if we expand the work load for
the school districts they're going to
have more work to do often times that
additional work could entail additional
man hours or another position so so my
my new question as of today is by
passing this are we creating any kind of
unfunded mandate at the school level uh
are are we forcing them to spend more
manpower to manage this program I think
I heard you say though that this is
already in law they're already doing it
they've already absorbed this right soti
so I want to hear you say that the no
there is no unfunded mandate in this no
there's no unfunded mandate no
additional one there already is yeah
they're already work the unfunded
mandates already happen correct and it's
such a rare occasion it's so few kids
that you know it would just be okay I I
I just get concerned about who's paying
the bill yeah the unfunded mandate
already exists this literally would be a
couple of kids in the state so it may be
a couple of case management hours during
the week or year but it's not going to
be an entire new position for somebody
because it's purely the case management
as these children are in court ordered
placements so it's not a whole lot of
man hours that go into managing these
students okay uh thank you are there
more questions okay so what I'd like to
have division three consider is is I'd
like to know if um by a show of hands if
you're meable to making the effective
date based on this amendment
1091 january1 2025 that that pushes it
off is is everyone amable to uh
postponing the effective
date what I'm confused because your
Amendment says July 1 2025 that's what I
tried to just say did I did my January
oh so my brain misfired you just caught
my brain misfired just double checking
then oh my God my brain misfired and
it's on live it's on recording so July 1
2025 is are is everyone amable to to
this postponement go
ahead oh you're raising your hand so
show of hands if you're meable to
suspending the effective date to July
1:25 okay all right so so then with that
I would like to postpone for go ahead
could I just ask I guess Nathan Mr White
um what does that mean if we
delay by I guess we're delaying by one
year what's the what what does that are
we gonna are we liable anyway for these
students if you if you delay the
effective date um that pushes us into
the next budget cycle we're going to
start to prepare
we're already working on our budget for
the next bium um we'll be submitting our
budget in September um globally our
budget is going to be increasing by
probably $200 million General funds up
to 20% once you fact over the prior Bia
once you factor into the medic $134
million of Medicaid rate increase
probably you know the forensic unit
coming online and there's another $25
million there dollars there so when I'm
when I'm setting up my budget I'm
looking at what are the prioritize needs
because I'm probably not going to get
all everything into the governor's
budget Target which may be flat zero or
negative um I I don't I don't I don't
know and so I think what would end up
happening is if you put forward
legislation like this um we would likely
have to put forward some sort of
prioritized need request in the next
budget to get this funded otherwise the
law would take effect and there would be
no funding
available
and could we ask well the same question
so I think what's going to happen is the
students what will happen is the state's
going to pay either way and the student
will just have to drop out of special
education so education Educators would
no longer participate and there'll be no
case management so I think you
conceivably could lose funding um
because you you're going to pay for it
either way and and and if a child has to
drop out a speci education in order to
continue with a placement it's it's you
know it's going to be devastating for
that child but it's also going to be a
continuation and case management for the
state they're not going to put these
children out on the
street and that already exists through
that 171a that we were talking about
that requires the student to make that
choice or the family to make that choice
of either continuing that placement and
keeping consistent services and
placement or um and dropping out of
special so it's it's in combination so
they can no longer receive Services
through the school in order to meet
dhs's policy um for not continuing in
school at that time in order to fund it
and that's not legislation that's just
policy that's policy okay so the
Practical implication if I'm hearing it
right from the people with the boots on
the ground is that uh the effective date
of this really should just go ahead and
say effective 60 days after it's passed
message
because coming up with a different
effective date is doesn't really impact
reality it'll I mean the schools will
step back and not be involved with these
with these with these okay so I'll
withdraw my
Amendment okay so so on the rest of 1588
I'm I'm uncomfortable having us pass it
to the full finance committee without a
little bit more precision and so since
we can delay this till Friday I would
like to go ahead and delay it but if we
don't have any better
numbers by Friday then we you know I I
guess we have to decide then what we're
going to do in the absence of good
information or precise
information is there any dispute about
how to handle
that representative walner so I assume
that what we're waiting on then for our
Friday decision is really the
possibility of Mr White reworking I know
he's not going to give us a new fiscal
note official but maybe taking a look at
the at the numbers of students and kind
of looking at and this new information
about not maybe needing case
workers um that seemed like that was a
very new piece of information that we
just
learned so that we don't need any other
amendments to the policy I don't I don't
think so I don't think anyone's
advocated just working the numbers right
I and and and I we may share this
opinion that it's just uncomfortable for
the committee subcommittee to pass its
work to the full finance committee
without some numbers that we're
confident in yeah good thank you all
right okay so so thank you is there
anything that you wanted to say that you
didn't get a chance to say no thank you
very much thank you that's it for
1588 uh we're going to uh try to resolve
that on Friday
um HB
1593 um I understand there's an
amendment to to this uh this is U making
an appropriation to DHHS to support
recreational activities for individuals
with developmental
disabilities um do you want to speak to
the am I assume it's your Amendment you
got your name on it uh it is okay do you
want from where you're at do you want to
do let's wait for Mickey to hand them
out
yep so just as a reminder this bill is
uh about U making services available to
those on the developmental disability
waiver uh that uh as of June 30th uh
they uh had expected to be part of their
continuing program and budget but then
um you know based on new information
they've been
withdrawn and those are services that
that come come with the tag recreational
activities uh we've talked through this
uh uh many many times and I think from
when first introduced in Health and
Human Services uh and then passed there
17 to3 and then on a Voice vote on the
floor uh We've amended it a few more
times uh to um and basically what this
amendment does that wasn't in Prior
amendments is provide uh for
accelerated beginning of this program
and in particular so that we have uh
reports and information that we can act
on what line item are you drawing our
attention to okay let's see
um because this this is a replace all
with section one so um yeah so it's hard
to hard to pull out uh first on
um uh
uh item SE Roman numeral 7 the
department shall enter uh issue an
interim report to the fiscal committee
on honor before April 1st 2025 the
report shall include data on utilization
the number of you uh individuals seeking
services in accordance with paragraphs 1
two and three the number of individuals
provided services and the types of
specific Services provided the total
cost of the service provided and other
relevant uh information uh Section 8
also says they will issue a final report
later on um so those are all new line 30
down to the bottom of the bill is all
new right and in addition line
23 the Department of Health and Human
Services shall contract with one or more
organizations such as an area agency to
assist in administering These funds with
the approval of the governor the
department May utilize is a sole source
procurement method to implement
recreational Services as quickly as
possible uh so the the the uh I I I
think the driving goal for having that
process was so that we would have
information with the next banian B
budget cycle about what kind of services
are being provided uh and you know begin
to think about whether these are things
that could fall back into the
developmental disability waiver or
whether uh uh they were going to be
needed for the next bium or we were have
to look for alternative uh funding
mechanisms right and what does what do
lines 18 and 22 do is this where because
because uh offline I had heard that we
had narrowed eligibility to um adults we
did that was with a prior Amendment uh
that I brought forth that that carried
over into here where where where is it
and that is uh 18 line 18 through 22 is
from a prior Amendment and that's make I
I I I can't translate all of these
various codes and rsas but is does that
translate into adults only with the let
let me let me just make sure I got the
right
place the line it says have the
individuals have graduated or exited the
school system which means that they
would not be having services from the
schools and are adults if I understand
it correctly Mr kbis
you you concur I do okay and that was
that was in uh the last last version
that we discussed but um we still felt
that um there was a desire if we could
do something to to have good information
to act from when we when this committee
or its successor meets that have
information to work on and and then was
it was it this bill Mr White or a
different Bill where there was some
concern that that the we may not have
accumulated enough data given that it
takes a while to establish the pro
program to begin with and in one of
these bills we needed to
be
aware that uh our date for asking for a
report may be a little early and I just
want to know if it was this bill or
something else yes so it was this bill
and on page one line 30 of the amendment
in front of you um the interim report is
due April 1st of
2025 and then there is looks like
there's a secondary report for September
30th of
2025 um and as part of that I'm assuming
that there would be funds available in
state fiscal year 26 um there are
there's not an appropriation here for
State fiscal year 26 but we would still
have that report to deliver so are those
report dates do they pass your common
sense test are we going to actually have
have data accumulated that's worth
reporting by one April the the provision
on line 25 the department May utilize a
soul Source procurement method um I
think that would give us some grounds it
it would still be a soul Source request
to to GNC but that would allow us to
move forward with the contract a little
sooner um than we would otherwise so we
could probably contract in 3 or 4 months
depending on um how ult the negotiation
process would be and then by April you
could at least have four or five six
months of data is it generally true that
soulle Source costs the state
less it depends who you
ask okay I thought I'd ask you but uh i'
I've I've seen scenarios all right okay
so so thank you
um I I would entertain a motion if we're
sort of done just making sure we
understand what this bill does and then
we can debate whether or not we agree
with it or not so is do you have an
amendment or excuse me I have a motion
to accept that's what I'm looking for
you want to do what you want to a motion
to accept the amendment all right is
there a second I second okay is there a
discussion on the
motion all right uh
um okay I I I was initially more
reluctant but this amendment uh applying
to uh adults uh has addressed my biggest
concern so uh I I I can see voting for
this and is there any other
discussion thank you Mr chair so I agree
that this is important to do right
Recreation is is a part of fulfilling
someone's life I my concern here
is we are also tasked with making sure
we're protecting those citizens who fund
all of this through General funds and at
some point we're raising funds to cover
this it's not real clear to me how much
of this is going to be covered from
federal funds how much of this is going
to be covered from State funds um even
if there is a match and they're picking
up half or two-thirds meaning the
federal government it's still coming out
of the pockets of people who are still
trying to make sure sure they can make
their ends meet so um while the
amendment's better and I I'm okay with
the amendment um I not sure I can
support either the amended bill as is or
as filed okay so so after this amendment
we'll vote on the under underlying bill
um any representative wer well looking
at the language on both the amendment
and the original Bill Roman one talks
about recreational activity and then it
says however the department Health and
Human Services received clarification
from the centers for Medicare and
Medicaid services that supports and
services that are recreational in nature
are not reimbursable Services Under the
Medicaid Program so it's you know it's
for training and that kind of thing but
taking them out to the Ball Game yeah I
think I think in in in a subject matter
expert can uh correct this if I'm
mistaken but I think what this um money
is intended to do is uh we we knew that
CMS restricted uh funding so that
recreational Services were not
reimbursable uh unless they had a a
documented therapeutic benefit to them
and and without one this bill is
intending to uh allow additional
recreational services to be reimbursed
uh to by the state St without dipping
into Federal money I think that's the
carve out I'm not sure that that word
however is is the best word to be using
there that sort of oh just I it's just
not clean but um but but I think that's
what it does is is that correct that we
we're trying to pay for the stuff that
Medicaid doesn't pay for yeah yeah does
that address your yes okay I want to
make sure we knew that yeah I I just
don't like the way I I think it could
have been written better but it go
ahead so can someone from the Department
give an estimate on how much of this is
going to be picked up by General funds
then it would be 100% um in section one
ROM to line beginning on line 15 the the
language the governor is otherwise or is
authorized to draw a warrant for set for
said sums out of any money in the
treasury not otherwise appropriated um
suggests it's 100% uh General
funds representative Stringham and then
representative Leon uh I agree with that
and that was the intent but I will also
kind of reate reiterate back when we did
the budget for the developmentally
disabled uh the budgets uh as written
included these Services uh for two years
and we were going to pay half and the
federal government is going to pay half
as it is uh they're not receiving them
for one year so overall we'll end up
spending about the same amount of money
out of General funds that we would have
if this change in the
program uh interpretation or rules
hadn't been made so but we still need to
appropriate it because it's in a
different bucket of of the uh budget
this year and
um that's that's it for
that um thank you and I'm relatively new
to all of this with the developmental de
abilities in that whole system but from
my understanding trying to work into it
is that New Hampshire had always had a
pretty decent amount of leeway in order
to best serve our people the best way we
knew how um as it's been moving forward
CMS has being become more and more
prescriptive of what can happen and
these Community Services these
recreational services are a lot are some
of the things that we try and make sure
happen School AED people and just making
sure that you can be a part of the
community so that's why this has been an
important thing to do because it's
looking to the whole person we need to
make sure that it's within reasonable
limits and I think this does it but um
we're basically reimagining how we
provide um services to developmentally
disabled people in New Hampshire and um
I think that continuing this during such
a time of change is particularly
important because they've had so much
ripped away from them in the last year
or two at least certainty has been
because they have a whole bunch of
questions about what's going to be
funded and how and that kind of stress
wears on
you represent wer microphone's on did
you have something you wanted to say
okay no um is there any other comment
did did I already ask for a motion on
this you already gave it did it get
seconded it got
seconded uh so are we done with the
discussion between division three on
whether or not we want to support this
bill or not I think I think we're done
so uh do you want to call the role on
this uh sure this is on
um uh house bill
1593 uh motion is ought to pass with an
amendment name Amendment um
1161 yeah 1161 thank
you uh representative Leon
yes representative Earth can I ask what
are we voting on the amendment or the
whole thing the am oh I'm
sorry guys C uh no no on the amendment
representative hle um
yes on the amendment representative
wer representative
walner representative tersi yes
representative Stringham yes
representative priest yes representative
Edwards yes vote being 8 to
one uh the amendment
passes um with that um let's uh are we I
I needed uh a motion on the underlying
bill Bill
1593 you you move who's any yeah I make
the motion to ought to pass with
Amendment um HP
1593 is there second second
second okay any discussion
now okay are you ready to take a
vote I am representative Lon yes
representative Earth no Representative
hle no representative
Wier representative walner
representative tersi yes uh Stringham is
yes representative priest yes
representative
Edwards no vote being six to three it
passes Finance three all right um thank
you very
much
okay
um
98 uh relative to the Department of
Health and Human Services management of
Social Security payments and veteran
benefits for children and Foster Care my
note here says that representative
walner has an amendment to this you
do right so I have representative walner
Amendment as well as some written resp
responses from the Department from
questions from your last work session so
I'll distribute those okay and and we're
just dealing with one Amendment though
uh correct
okay
sh
all right we've talked about House Bill
1598 a few times um there was a a new
fiscal note that was done on this uh
that was uh
[Music]
231 and as I look at my
notes I don't I don't see the that
amendment to 23 the fiscal note
2311 does anyone have a copy of it uh or
maybe could just tell me what the impact
turned out to
be
sure oh I actually stapled it it just
looked oh
okay yeah it Revis
okay um so this was uh basically a a a $
2.87 million a year program um with a a
lower amount in the initial year and um
do do you do you want to talk to either
go ahead discuss either the 1598 itself
or your amendment to it you talk to the
amendment all
right
me
okay so I think that um the amendment
basically would um cause the uh fiscal
note to to change drastically this this
would be changed a lot um when I did in
the amendment was um two things it
basically stripped the
um bill of starting the program
immediately and or within the next year
what it did was it gave the depart it
gives the department one position and
this person this position would be a
program specialist and they would be a
specialist in Social Security and
veterans benefits so as children came
into
placement
residential and we're going into
residential placement with the
Department um there would be someone
there that would be doing the work to um
see if children are eligible for these
benefits this was something that came up
um numerous times during the discussions
on this bill and the second part is in
order to get ready for the
implementation of um the program not
really a program but the implementation
of the bill um the department came to me
and talked to me about getting having a
consultant who would help them develop a
report that would outline what they
would need to do to implement to
implement the program so that's um
section four of the amendment it
basically um replaces the bill this
replaces is all of the bill so it would
be one position to help them with the
eligibility for children who come into
the system and then um the consultant
which would help them um develop a
report and how this program would be
implemented um and it then it also um
would take effect on July 1 2025 the
next budget year
the program would start in the next
budget
year
question discussion on the
amendment you you you you you may you
made a uh a qualitative comment about
that um based on this we're probably
going to see a significantly lower
fiscal note do you have a a a wag number
a wild ask I get I think the fiscal note
would be the two sections added together
one the consultant I have in this
amendment the consultant being
$200,000 and the
position I'm not sure how much the
position is probably in the neighborhood
of sit in the neighborhood of
110,000 is what we need to cover a
position so that would be I guess that
would be the new fiscal
note you're welcome to come up if you
want
to and and we're not holding you to
account for these we're just looking for
a little more
data I I I don't intend to finish the
vote on this until Friday so this is
we're we're really in a conversation
mode because I think the amendment
changes the terrain yeah um so in in
just quickly glancing at this um so the
$106,000 is appropriated in section
three of the amendment for the position
so in the first year in state fiscal
year
25 your total cost would be 306,000
um dollar $200,000 being for the
consultant the remaining
106 um being for the position um we
because section one would still go into
effect July 1 of
2025 um we would still have an estimated
roughly $2.1 million general fund impact
um so our DCF budget would need an
additional $2 million as we've already
discussed based on the offset revenue
and then um the estimates that we had
previously provided were for
um additional positions to take on the
work of man managing um the new trust
accounts that we currently do not in in
the manner as described in the
bill
questions you you know what would be
helpful to me is is uh the simplest of
all little Excel tables that that sort
of organizes what you just said
um
just a tiny little Excel
table um so what what I propose doing
and I'm open for other opinions on this
is i' I'd like us to
um absorb the amendment and um and then
come back on Friday and it should not
take long to determine what we want to
do as a group so I I'm comfortable
postponing this and if you could just
give us a new number just informal
um you it's your Amendment do you want
to do it
differently okay that sounds fine to me
okay um thank
you all right um so we're postponing uh
recessing I guess 1598 to finalize it on
Friday um and then so that brings us
to hb1
1573 um so we have at least a couple of
amendments um and to make it simple why
don't we have chairman Pearson come
forward um
and um representative walner uh you have
an amendment as
well okay so and I think maybe um the
child advocate or um someone from do you
do you want Miss Sanchez to step forward
or or I think the the deputy
who worked on putting this all um this
amendment together okay Miss Sanchez
jump all whoever you want to have step
forward okay I guess
not uh yes representment on
this there there is an official uh I'm
I'm going to refer to it for the course
of the day as the Pearson Amendment and
the number you're looking at and the
Pearson amendment is about to be handed
to you I oh then okay this is
unofficial I could use I could use
another to tell you the truth I gave my
walner one away repres walner actually
thank you if he'd gotten an autographed
it would have been worth more yeah
right word STS right there
okay all
right okay so I have 1183 oh that's
1598 I have 1180 and I have
1184 are those the two amendments we're
talking about I think
so
so so Miss
Morris would you just go ahead and
preposition at the end of the table
where you could grab that microphone we
may need to come to
you okay I think this is the most
complicated bill that division 3 has
taken on this year um and I I just to
level set everyone the way I view it is
uh it's a it's an important bill uh we
had a very bad incident
outplaced and um and the office of the
child advocate led a great investigation
and Report summarizing the problems it
stimulated a lot of concern and a lot of
action a bill was put together went
through children and family law came to
us in what off of the consent calendar
did do I remember that right it came so
I'd like to believe that yeah so so and
when we first started here in
1573 we heard that the committee looked
at the policy loved the policy but
didn't really look at the financial
impact so that created a bunch of
turmoil uh to try to take a look at what
the policy committee uh had proposed and
the house had passed and and to to
reinvent it in a way re-engineer it in a
way in which we still protected our kids
we still gave ourselves the assurance
that we were actually protecting our
kids and but we did it in a way in which
uh the workload requirements were a
little bit different and as a result we
were able to anticipate A reduced spend
on this so tremendous work has taken
place Miss moris of DHHS has done a
great job of coordinating with chairman
Pearson and OCA and with the Judiciary
right right the Judiciary is here okay
would you have a seat next to Miss
Morris thank
you okay and and so so the maturity of
what we're looking at and I I I don't
want to prejudge representative walner
Amendment because I haven't had a chance
to see it but the maturity I think of
1573 as represented in representative
Pearson's amendment is that they've done
a great job at figuring out where the
department and the OCA agreed to agree
and they have a couple of points where
they don't agree and that's really the
driver behind the reason we're looking
at two amendments I don't want to call
one the DHHS Amendment the other one OCA
that's a little oppositional but we have
different points of view that's why we
have different amendments the maturity
part of the Pearson Amendment uh is uh I
I I'm not comfortable that the judicial
branch has really had an opportunity to
to to get in integrated into this
amendment and by integrated what I mean
is the initial fiscal note came out with
two judges and and seven clerks um which
created a fairly significant financial
impact and that's not our division but
so I'm trying to represent division well
here one well here and what I had asked
you to do and I don't know if you've had
an opportunity to really do this to
where you're comfortable with it that's
why I want you to be able to speak is
um the the The Logical flow of events is
that we write a law the law gets
implemented it has uh workload and
Workforce
implications that the work load and
Workforce implication gets represented
in our budgets and we pay for what we
say we're going to do when we're writing
the law we have an opportunity to work
the other way if if we take a look at
what we think we want to do and it has a
significant Workforce or workload
implication then we can work back
towards amending or coming up with a
different way to WR the law so that
we're still accomplishing the objective
with the lower overhead and and that was
the challenge I put to the judicial
branch we don't do judicial stuff so so
I needed you all to take a look at the
language and figure out if there's a way
to accomplish the objective in a more
efficient
way so just real short do do do you feel
like you've had time and an opportunity
to integrate the your branches opinion
on the way the workforce or workload
ought to be scoped by this law thank you
Mr chairman uh my name is Erin krian I'm
the general counsel for the judicial
branch I believe I was able to see um if
not a final a near final of both
versions um I think that some of the
intentions of the Pearson version were
they were not written exactly as they
were scripted to be correct yeah they
didn't make it into the amendment but
yeah but I I I was able to look at both
Alternatives and part of the reason I
look at both Alternatives is ultimately
we're not a we're not a policy player in
this discussion we're just rendering
fiscal estimates for the different
visions of how much increased Court
oversight there will be in in different
scenarios and the original estimate that
we had which was about 1.6 million was
based on uh
having a large number of extra hearings
a year which even with the draft that
OCA has done uh which I understand have
to be the one that is under the name of
Representative walner um would already
be haved so it would already be closer
to 800,000 to implement that Vision um
the one that I understand is is an
alternative which may be more cost
effective But ultimately the legislature
has to judge whether the costs and
benefits equalize in that scenario uh
reduces the number of hearings even
further so that our costs would fall
under 400,000 closer to about
350,000 uh so there there are reduced
costs to both Alternatives um one is
still a higher number of hearings one is
lower and hearings are just something
that does cost uh money to increase
should should I do I hear you right that
there may be a a third alternative that
would have a more efficiency yet than
either of these two I think it's not
represented in the Pearson dra but it
was intended to be um to to consolidate
all the follow-on hearings of the
original 30-day hearing into the
existing ing 90day uh review hearings
that already occur and if that were the
case then our our costs come down
significantly with the consolidation but
I believe both drafts currently have a
30-day hearing and a 60-day follow on
okay I'm I just got to keep it really
simple so I can
track right now
11484 basically gets close to what you
think would be the most efficient method
but the words that that you think we
ought to have are not yet in this
amendment so we have we don't have your
words anywhere in any in either of these
amendments I I was able to look at them
both and and give feedback the costs are
different based on the different policy
intentions um but I think that the
policy intention That was supposed to be
in 1184 has not made it into the draft
yet um but if it when it does uh it will
it will be the cheapest of the three
alternatives one that's about 1.6
million one that's like cheap but cost
effective yeah whether it's cost
effective is is your your adjudication
because there's obviously a cost in
terms of the policy as well and and
that's something that you're you're
weighing but there's there's one Vision
which is the original which is about 1.6
million I think the walner amendment is
about 800,000 and the uh Pearson
amendment is under 350 or so okay so um
sorry to steal your thunder but I just
wanted to get the judicial because they
they haven't had as many opportunities
to talk about this and and and I that my
perception was that that there there a
there's still a little bit of lag
between their observations and what's in
a written Amendment opportunity so do
you want to speak to us U Mr chair thank
you Mr chairman uh I feel like I'm in a
College reunion here because we have
worked a lot on this and in good faith
from everybody
um my experience here and we came into
the house together we're both in our
eighth year and the experiences of many
of us is during the process of hearings
and craftings and back and forth things
and so on some departments and agencies
already start doing it they don't wait
for the law to be signed they see some
good ideas they hear some wonderful
thoughts and quite a bit of this bill is
amended by either
Amendment uh dhh tells me they're
already starting to work on and that
encourages me and it also takes the
pressure off because um I think we have
about a inch and a half stack of
amendments on this single bill and I
don't think we're done yet certain
things we had hoped would be in
amendments didn't get in there we hope
they had I don't know who dropped the
ball it's not important but they're not
there
since the
department who will be implementing this
is already doing a lot of this I might
suggest the best way forward is interim
study and for me interim study is not
death With Dignity here yes sir could
you hold on one second is there
something going on that I need to know
about I just want to clarify I just
learned that so I believe the the
language that's in the Pearson Amendment
today was the language that was provided
to OS Friday and new language may have
come over the weekend which has not been
drafted yet no I double checked my email
um the language I sent them on Friday
there were three parts that they missed
three lines so I just may have been my
fault for producing an amendment today
that maybe wasn't the latest inred oh no
this it's no it's nobody's fault we're
we're building the plane while we're
trying to fly it is the is the issue I'm
sorry to to cut off there I just wanted
to I think there is something still at
ol I just wanted to make that clear
that's my understanding and and I even
think the stuff that's at OS may not
actually fully incorporate what's in the
judicial Branch's mind in terms of the
the best way to the optimum way that's
the good way to say cheap the optimum
way to do this well I uh I I I suppose I
I can never say enough that the balance
of the cost and the policy that you want
to come to is not one that we would take
a position on um there is certainly a
cost alternative but that is not the one
that the legislature has to adopt it's
ultimately your determination where to
spend the dollars you were so good and
I'm just teasing me a little bit but uh
we think it they fund it you do it
that's exactly right yeah so I you got
interrupted do you remember where you're
at represent Pearson
okay because they're already starting to
implement many of the good ideas that
came out of this entire process I I
believe that takes the pressure off
because we have a stack of amendments
that big and it's likely to get bigger
with the deadline looming ever ever
closer I might suggest interim study
which for me is never death With Dignity
it's let's take the pressure off let's
spend some time more time with Judiciary
more time and make some good
recommendations while the good ones are
already being implemented I might
suggest so I I hear your suggestion and
the the S the the distinction I found
between real interim study and and just
a death With Dignity is that there is a
uh key legislator willing to own the
interm study process I think we could
find that person well who who do we
think we might find you've already asked
me so are you on record saying if there
was an interim study you would continue
to own this issue I would okay now now
I'll come to you in just a second but so
Miss Morris um a statement was made by
representative Pearson that a lot of the
good ideas that have come out of all the
brainstorming and writing and discussion
that the department is already working
and has and got various amounts of this
already uh in in progress or in place
could would you like
to make that more clear to us sure so
our team the d uh sorry the team with
DCF and bcbh the ones who do the monthly
visits as well as do the certification
visits annually they meet with the OCA
monthly to discuss policies um any other
items of note and so that way they can
our team can can bring that back and
tweak policies uh tweak procedures as
necessary now the spirit of the the bill
we definitely support uh but some of the
items would require fiscal uh implic uh
Appropriations in order to move forward
some of the larger real ticket items
including you know increased visits and
things of that nature but otherwise
there's nothing to stop us from moving
forward with many of the policies that
that are laid out in
here all right you're up thank you
chairman
Edwards um this is the first the OCA has
heard of this we are not in agreement
with their term study we believe that um
we've worked closely with representative
Pearson with DHHS with the Judiciary we
met with um the subcommittee last week
yourself and uh representative walner
representative P priest sorry excuse me
um it had a very productive conversation
I believe that representative walner
Amendment 1180 which everyone has does
strike that balance now I appreciate you
not saying it's the OCA Amendment and
the DHHS Amendment because to be frank
they're about 97% the same we have been
working on this since last November
really since last August I believe that
1180 is ready to pass now um you got
this fun Excel spreadsheet I heard how
much you like Excel spreadsheets
chairman
Edwards um as well as you got a document
that says at the top OCA proposal
31524 um I know this has been really
confusing with all the replace all
amendments so what we tried to do was
this OCA proposal is comparing
representative walner Amendment with
what passed the house as hb1 1573 in
February because when you do the replace
all there's not the strikeouts in the
italics so this document shows you what
differences is from what you guys
already passed policy-wise
this document is to really capture those
three buckets and where there remain
differences between represent ative
walner Amendment and representative
Pearson's Amendment and as I said it's
extremely small we have actually come to
complete agreement around the DCF
monthly worker visits 100% the
same the judicial um section so there's
a header here that says dcyf monthly
worker
visits just comparing the the walner
amendment and the Pearson Amendment we
did also add a column for the fiscal
impact which we talked about pretty in
depth at the subcommittee meeting last
week but I wanted to make sure the rest
of you could see that the Amendments
that were made between two weeks ago and
today really have significant fiscal
impact and I just heard Aon uh describe
those for the judicial piece um so the
judicial piece the court oversight piece
the primary difference right now between
the two amendments the office of child
advocate would still like to see that
middle range that Aon just described
where they not your your Bargain
Basement price of $350,000 but the
middle price of
$800,000 where um the policy goal of the
bill as passed in February was really to
get children out of residential
placement as quickly as possible reduce
the cost of placement um so by having
just a single 60-day hearing and then
going back to the routine hearings that
doesn't really add that much additional
judicial oversight um so that is really
the only difference is you know the
walner amendment says one 60-day hearing
and then continue to have 60-day
hearings whereas I'm not sure what it
actually says but the goal was to just
go right back the new wner Amendment
Cuts those 30-day hearings down just one
30-day hearing then to 60-day hearings
which is where that significant cost
savings happened so really the big
difference between these two amendments
is in the middle bcbh certification team
section um the compromise already
occurred going from quarterly visits
which is what was in the b the original
bill you all passed at the end of
February reached a compromise going to
twice a year visits with one being
unannounced the language discussed at
the subcommittee last week was still
doing those annual recertification
visits as it stands in administrative
rule right now you're not going to keep
a facility certified that you are not
visiting the OCA ask was that okay so if
you're doing an annual visit just doing
your recertification thing that you
always do right now under in you know
administrative rule if you're about to
send a kid there and you haven't been
there in several months go take a quick
visit before you send a kid there um we
thought we were in agreement on that
there was language around that and then
this amendment that we did receive the
language Sunday night on now says the
the Pearson Amendment if there's not a
kid there we're not even going to do the
recertification visits we're not going
to visit at all if there's no kid there
we're going to conditionally certify
which from the OC standpoint is frankly
a liability issue you now have a roster
of certified placements that you're not
visiting at all and then you're
essentially going to have to go back out
and do a certification visit before a
kid goes so we are in agreement before a
child gets there you need to make sure
that place is okay
so I hope that by laying it out this way
it makes a little bit more sense of what
changes are being made from what you all
passed in February as hb1 1573 and then
this lays out really those just minor
differences
between representative Pearson's
Amendment today and representative
wahner's Amendment today but really I
think the policy that you all passed at
the end of February that would you know
address the safety of children is an
important one I think we're so close
right now that interim study um is not
necessary I think you have a really good
amendment in front of you and I'm happy
to answer any questions um other about
where the fiscal impact was or the
policy
stuff I think I have a couple questions
for you
uh let's let's say for example you're I
I think I heard you that you you you
would like instead of having a
conditional certification an
organization and a conditional
certification that you would either want
to terminate their certification or go
ahead and do the inspections to keep
them fully certified well you don't like
the conditional part that's current law
now so under current administrative rule
if a facility is to maintain its
certification it must have an annual
in-person visit from bcbh in order to
remain certified so that's a new thing
that DHHS is putting forward now that
now they'd like to not even do those
required annual visits and just have
this conditional certification sort of
on the books without going to see them
or doing the certification but they
don't have any kids in them when they're
in a conditional status no New Hampshire
they have children but no New Hampshire
children correct okay but there would
still be a place so one distinction
there is we're talking about D CF placed
children so Child Protection or Juvenile
Justice yeah if a facility remains
certified though that does mean that
bcbh could be offering that placement to
parents that are doing voluntary
placement that the the kids still with
the parents and so the parents are
seeing a list of certified
facilities that have that that title
certification they're not State Place
children children so the same rules
don't apply as far as what we're doing
here um as well as um schools also make
placements in some of those facilities
so it I think you're you're entering a
potentially liable gray area where
you're keeping facilities on the books
as approved by the state of New
Hampshire but without any of the
paperwork or oversight or visits which
just that's a new gray area we're
creating here which I'm not sure why we
would do that it would be a new category
too though it would be neither not
certified nor certified it would
be new thing called conditional
certification I have no idea how that
would be reflected it's it's not in the
current law okay so if they had the
money available the law allowed them to
do conditional certification but if they
had the ability and the the resources to
go and keep a certification current they
can they could do that regardless of the
law could they not they could they could
choose as a policy matter to do that
instead of a legal compliance
choice I guess they could do anything
they wanted I'm just not sure why you
would put that into law because we
talked about this in a work session
where where I I'm I'm just concerned
that we um don't present a litigation
Target by establishing standards that we
don't have confidence are going to uh
have resources sustained uh not just
this budget but the next budget the
budget there I mean we're talking about
forever if we put this in the law until
it gets changed so I'd rather have a
lower litigation risk because of the law
and more policy implementation by the
department that that that's that's my
point of view I absolutely hear what
you're saying the current administrative
rules that the department follows now
has those annual visits presumably
they've budgeted and staffed for those
annual visits the purpose of this
legislation was to
create a higher standard strong not even
a higher standard but clearer standards
so to then say remember those
administrative rules we told you we were
going to bulk up so we didn't need a
statute now we'd rather actually make a
statute that's even less protective than
the current process just I it just
doesn't make sense to us for from where
we're coming from of what the purpose of
this bill is okay representative walner
there's been a lot of talk about your
Amendment do you want to say something
about your Amendment you I'll come to
you representative wer well I want to
say that there's been certainly been a
lot of work on it and I've got a quite a
big stack of amendments um both from the
department and from the office of child
advocate I think we're really close and
a lot of work has gone on to on this I
know chairman Pierce's um committee I
think you sent this to the floor
unanimously and I think you know your
committee worked on it this committee
certainly put in a lot of time on it so
I think interim study um is really not
necessary this time I think we've done a
lot of study and the two committees have
really come close and the two the
department and the and the Advocate have
come really close um I think Lisa just
said
97% that's pretty good I said 95 but
I'll take yours it's pretty good so well
we we share 98% of our DNA with
chimpanzees though so well so I I would
I would like to see us be able to get
something ready to go to the full
committee and then on to the floor um I
think this
is the report if you read the report I
think you'll see how serious this issue
is
and New Hampshire has already had some
pretty terrible
experiences around children in
placement and I think that we need to be
proactive will everything in this law
this bill if it passes will everything
be perfect probably not I've never saw
I've never seen perfect yet but we have
the opportunity to come back here in
January after they've been working on
this to put it in place we come back
here in January to do those tweaks where
it doesn't work bring in something that
you know makes it work better but I do
think that we need to move forward and
um to delay this is not um probably not
a benefit to the state Mr chairman wait
and you considered the Pearson Amendment
and you you find it inadequate which is
why you submitted another amendment a
different Amendment oh well I didn't
really see the I had the Pearson
amendment was still coming in my mailbox
right up until Sunday night when I went
to bed so um me too okay so in all the
efforts we still haven't right gotten
okay I understand you know um Lisa put
together
this piece that really outlines where
the differences are and I think that
would be really helpful if we could sort
of focus in on the differences because
we're really right down to just a few
places so so representative
wer there's so much in this that's P
policy that we're not equipped to do
that we're just loaded with stuff coming
up on a deadline you don't have a lot of
time I would move interim
study um Mr chairman is did you intend
that to be a formal motion looking for a
second I
did that's
seconded uh is there a discussion on the
motion before
us go go
ahead if you do not decide interim study
I would very much suggest that since
DHHS will be implementing
this you take their Amendment because
they'll be implementing
it we appreciate DHHS appreciates right
the work of many different ones right
but this will be dhs's job right so so
okay so thank you I to the discussion on
interim study whatever we do in finance
in the next couple of weeks is not the
end of this there the the Senate is
working on a a parallel bill I believe
we're going to end up getting that bill
probably back into division three in a
couple of
months um I I don't I don't see our
disposing of this bill as interim study
to be a a problem because I I suspect
Miss Morris and miss krian and and OCA
you you everyone's going to continue
trying to F refine this so we've got got
like one way to go and if we pass this
this becomes the house position and if
and and and then I think that would
limit us in a u Committee of conference
uh a bit I I I I would like to just re
retain some freedom of movement on this
knowing that we're going to we're not
done with this we're going to get this
in a couple of months that that's my
point of view I'm I I'm I'm leaning
towards interim study on this
sir go go
wait did that was you yeah so the Senate
bill hb1 1573 has some pretty essential
pieces that are not in any other bills
particularly 1573 the one before us
correct the the findings but the
creation of that new
certification team that entire section
is nowhere else the only only sections
that overlap with Senate Bill 417 which
did just pass the Senate Judiciary
Committee policy committee last week
unanimously is the section about the
dcyf workers which we are in complete
agreement on they're identical between
these two bills as well as the judicial
oversight portion which frankly I would
say at this point this
version is better in either of these
bills um because the Judiciary did weigh
in about uh the motion practice piece of
it which was very important so while
those two pieces would certainly meet in
the middle um
the policy piece of this about
reducing children being in institutional
placements and languishing in those
placements and the creation and
increased oversight of that bcbh
certification team including the
Appropriations that would allow them to
create that team because we can talk
about it all we want but if those
positions don't
get created that nothing's going to be
done to
improve that
process so I'm sorry I have to truncate
a lot of this so I can store it the the
what I think I heard you say in there
that's really important to me is that um
the uh the certification part of
1573 is not in the Senate version and
and if we wanted to be additive to the
process I hate I hate to say it but that
sounds like it could be a really simple
smaller amendment that we could pass out
of here uh instead of all of the moving
parts we just narrow it down because I
don't I don't see a lot of movement you
guys aren't disputing the certification
piece much other than whether or not
they should have this gray area of um of
partial certification or whatever the
term was I mean to be honest that is the
major point of contention here in this
room today is how far back the
department has scaled that certification
team's responsibilities in this Sunday
night Amendment okay so is there more
discussion on the motion before the
committee on interim study
representative walner well I am opposed
to the interim study I think I already
said that but um we don't interim study
amendments we would be interest studying
the bill as it came so just so that
there's no I thought there was
some reference to interim studying one
of one or the other of the Amendments
but could include all of the Amendments
um well this will all be available this
will all be available it's part of the
record whoever's doing the interim study
can use whatever materials that are done
already right I mean yeah so we're just
interim studying
1573 right so don't throw your files
away that's what you're saying yeah
don't throw the flow um I just I I
really feel like we've done so much work
and the children and family law
committee has done enormous amount of
work on this the um child advocate and
the department have worked on it and
we're so close it feels like we really
it would really make sense for us to
pass this we we're going to if the other
bill from the Senate comes over it would
be nice to have a house position and
this would be our position as we
negotiate with the Senate around this
rep represent wer this is unprecedented
to have so many moving Parts when it
comes to us just to make a financial
decision not looking at 16 different
policy things that's not our purview
we're looking here to look at the costs
and the money and if there were two
different Alternatives we'd look at one
or the other but because this needs to
have all the incorporation of the other
committees if it's interim study they
can be incorporated so that it's not a
policy change looking like it came from
the finance committee and we'd be
criticized for that so that's why I'm
saying interim study you need to get all
these things included thank you
representative
priest thank you Mr uh chairman um what
if we just delay the decision on this
until Friday and that would give an
opportunity for both sides to come
together and see if we could come up
with something that had the
fiscal um analysis in there that we can
then make an assessment
on I I can give you an answer to that my
answer would you like to do that
representative Weller I'd say if they
can come to a conclusion by Friday
presented before us at that meeting in
no less than 25 we got so many bills on
there I don't want to pick another hour
talking about this stuff when we've got
like 40 bills before us Friday is just
us though Friday is another work session
in division three it's not your full
finance committee either way yeah it's
you know if if they have something by
Friday then we could overturn the
interim study the the we could uh the
the challenge I think at this point U is
that we we we still don't have Clarity
on exactly which one Amendment we should
adopt it doesn't sound like the judicial
language is in either Amendment to the
extent that it could be uh this whatever
the amendment would be would trigger
some more math to give us some idea I I
don't I don't I don't I I just am having
a hard time perceiving in the next four
days the the completion of a a a and
agreed upon Amendment the incorporation
of the judicial input and another round
of fiscal analysis so that we know what
we're voting on Friday but if if that
Miracle could happen I I would bring it
up again but but I I just don't believe
it the walner amendment is correct and
complete as drafted by OSS and I I
believe Erin's
$800,000 reflects the intent and the
language of the walner
amendment the way she said it right but
there's a lower
alternative and there are a few points
that OCA has stood fast on the DHHS
which will be implementing this doesn't
like yeah so so we do we have a valid
motion before us um inter study you have
a question comment
representative thank you um this is for
chairman Wier it's my understanding at
least on regular policy committees that
any member having voted on the
prevailing side or the non-prevailing
side can make a motion for
reconsideration as long as the bill is
within the committee is that true for
finance divisions as well
yes
so it doesn't lock out anybody from
bringing this up Friday if we take a
vote today if they believe they've come
with a new solution and all of this
happens before we get to the executive
session for the full committee
yeah and all it is is a recommendation
so it can come before the committee on
whenever it it's completed and it's just
a recommendation someone else can say I
don't agree with the recommendation I
have an alternative and it's always open
until that's
done I guess my comment is why would we
even do an interum study now why it
sounds like we're putting off the um
decision until Friday to see if we can
get
closer to put on pressure to make sure
it's ready well I think the I think I
think they realize there's the pressur
is there I mean an interim study can
come forth on Friday if that's if that's
the decision if not
um we would have an amendment that we
could
adopt okay I hear you I I I think we
have a valid Motion in front of us is
there any further
discussion are you ready to take a
role yes I am this is on the motion is
interim study for house bill
1573 and the voluminous documents that
are available so don't throw them away
um uh representative Leon yes
representative Earth yes representative
hle yes representative Wier yes
Representative
walner no Representative tersi no uh
representative Stringham votes no
representative Priest No and chairman
Edwards uh yes the vote being five to
four the motion of interim study
passes so so like we said if a miracle
occurs and we can come up with a
relatively straight
forward simple set of decisions on
Friday I I'm open to reconsidering this
but at this time it just seems to me to
be just too much mush uh not cooked
enough to make a a professional
recommendation to the finance committee
so Mr chairman uh yes may I just add one
thing I still for what what was referred
to a spreadsheet haven't seen any
numbers other than judicial gave us an
update so it' be nice if by Friday there
was a number that substitutes for the
what's it $6 million that's currently in
there now right right so um when we talk
about spreadsheets we talk about where
the finance committee um it'd really be
nice to see the right the numbers thank
so that's a this is a little bit uh more
difficult um because we need judicial
numbers in there too judicial gave us
the numbers they said was 800k 1 case
and 35 other case that's fantastic but
there are the smaller numbers of the of
the bigger picture the bigger picture is
like 6 million
so it' be nice to know what the
replacement number is there for all
these changes right I'm obsessed with
the judicial just because uh it's
division one and I want to be
parsimonious with their money well I I
guess I'm trusting that at least they
come up with
numbers uh representative walner I just
wanted to point out for representative
or I think if you take the um this
document there are some estimates there
of fiscal impact can you just tell me
where well in the third column I
included what was in the original let me
be clear what I'm looking for is it so
here we
go we go to the last page judicial gave
us a bottom line number down here for
both cases I'd like to see a bottom line
number down there for both cases of the
other aspects of this whole thing just
as you would see in a fiscal note thanks
thank you thank
you
okay so I think that concludes hp1 1573
for the day uh as far as the work
session goes um uh I think I think we I
think we did a lot and uh and we're not
done but we've at least reduced the uh
the amount of things we have to finalize
on Friday because Friday is truly our
drop dead date so um thank you very much
uh you have any words of wisdom for us
Mickey uh the only thing I can say is
I've got the two amendments that we had
talked about earlier today you adopted
them without the number I do have those
to oh that's great let I I don't want to
re this I want to hand those out and
make sure everyone sees them and and see
if anyone changes their mind now that
they see
them
almost to see if I can get the little
guy
yeah
yeahor tues we start at 10
o' to
get
problems is that
today
Mi Mr chair these look brilliant
brilliantly
written mag magnificent uh Pros I'm only
seeing the one 1282 was there a second
one yeah
1595 oh okay I was dist I distracted
myself so so nobody uh we've got two in
front of us does anyone have any
concerns we're okay with our previous
vote with the insertion of these uh
numbers all right well uh that'll be it
um we're we're we're Jour for the day
okay right yes sir 10 o'clock
tomorrow
e